[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous jure sérail comme l'avait dit
bien sûr où tu as usa mais alors j'étais
jeune je veux dire voilà ça c'est du
johnny plaire non merci très bien mais
je suis chez moi c'est votre attaché de
presse qui nous l'a dit ah ben non par
amar exact qu'elle était membre du jury
de la star academy il a été membre du
jury de la star academy stomie passé
c'est pas si bien sûr saison s'est t on
à la vidéo
[Musique]
vous allez les aider parce que le
jugement ça va être finalement un coup
de pouce on va essayer de juger au mieux
on va essayer de voir la performance de
voir l'artiste qui va se dépasser on m'a
dit que c'était une très belle sélection
cette année donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
très content même si chaque fois les
gens me demandent si c'était compliqué
ou pas mais non en studio tous les jours
des chanteurs à voix fine voix haute on
en voit tous les jours
donc c'était franchement actifs thé ou
de l'ouest c'est bien de voir aussi la
lumière dans les dents dans les yeux des
participants à ça ils vivent à un truc
spécial donc j'ai eu c'était une grosse
saison ça de la star ac alors